In the fragment detailed layout,
a text view is already defined.
We have to assign it an ID
so that within the detail fragment
of detail activity we can use
view by ID to find the text view.
To determine the forecast info
that the text view should display,
we can access the intent
that the detail activity was launched by.
We're going to use
this inside of onCreateView.
(clicking, pressing key)
Since we added an intent extra
with the forecast data there,
we can read that intent extra
back to display in the text view.
As you can see, we pulled
the forecast string
from the intent, find our rootView,
and then set the text
to that forecast string.